when do you get like your first Brazier
or whatever like do they and how do you
even get that do they like mail it to
you or something like how do you even
get like you gotta uh I stole my first
one really yeah I stole my first one I
was scared so I don't have a good
relationship with my mom so I'm gonna be
like Mom let's go get a bra yeah I was
like tally and my best friend let's go
to the mall let's steal bras yeah yeah
we sold thongs we sold bras I didn't
need one though I still didn't I got a
boob job so I didn't ever need one yeah
were you just very more Lane chested
kind of yeah yeah it was lean there was
nothing there
damn buddy yeah yeah buddy that's
everyone called me oh it is yeah that's
buddy like damn little brother yeah it's
like [__] yeah I always I guess I know I
never wondered that but I guess I was
just thinking about that yeah like do
you how do you get a bra if you're a
girl like yeah it was like the
government like mail you like your first
bra or is it like they give you this
book actually in fifth grade they gave
all these girls a book and it like shows
you all the different size and nipples
and all the different size of boobs and
then it shows you where you can go yeah
it's the best book ever wow that's cool
yeah teaches you about like periods and
stuff it does everything everything and
who gives it to you a parent gives it to
the child I'm sure no it was um it was
always the it was a nurse oh at school
yeah that's cool yeah it wasn't
parenting yeah do the YMCA man I fell in
love with a girl there one time because
she um
she had tits right nobody'd ever seen
him ever I mean none of our friends I
remember we came like damn what's wrong
with her you know I think she has cancer
like on her chest like beautiful cancer
you know because she just had these you
know she had them growths on her we'd
never seen it and uh
she ended up getting killed years later
oh I know it wasn't cancer
I don't know what got it that'd be crazy
if it was but
she got murdered or she what if it was
breast cancer that she died I hate to
say that because it's very sad and it
takes a lot of people but
I wouldn't be shocked that she had so
much young was she with the breasts I
mean I don't know
we didn't know what they were like I
remember were they like somebody thought
she was having twins or something
because you saw like two heads coming
out of her body where there's veins we
didn't see them that good
damn I mean we drew so many pictures of
them
yeah like I remember we'd shake each
other and be like describe our [__]
tits to me like we were like we really
really were excited you know we couldn't
help but we were just human males yeah
um how old when you're a human male how
old do you start getting excited about
tits
like when are you like wow
well I think there's two things or one
there's like a physiological part of it
physiological is that a word that
physiological physiological
your body you can't help it
like you'll be like um
your all your blood will run to the like
all your blood will run to the front of
your body if a woman's around okay like
literally you'll feel the back of your
body just kind of [__] like sag a
little like you're just yeah go cold
like you're so there's just you can't
help that right and so and that's what
happens with your wiener your wiener is
just the it's like the I was a
forerunner for it yeah it's like uh you
know on a turkey whenever it gets warm
enough in that thing pot it's just like
that it's like this is like some of the
blood's like hey we found a way and it's
like hey this is as far as we can go you
know oh yeah just yeah it's just an
arrow that's it it's like yeah it's like
over there yeah oh okay yeah so uh so
that happens but then there's another
there's like a visual thing that's kind
of happens I think
um
when somebody has brat and you start to
see them you know and then your real
kind of so there's that thing going on I
think there's two things but I don't
know what age it's at
just whenever you hit whenever you hit
puberty
but it can be before that if somebody
like gets you real visually intrigued so
you're almost intrigued from like a
curious standpoint because you know one
day you can't you're gonna care writer
you just wonder what's going on here
something's changing I want to know I'm
curious what's happening
um and then I was at summer camp and
they had a guy and he was dating one of
the counselors and like you said it was
through YMCA so it was just like yeah
they're just like the oldest kids
and he would let us look down his
girlfriend's shirt for a little while no
yeah
yeah his girlfriend yeah yeah he like
kind of got off on it or something at
the park
so I remember especially if it rained
out and there wasn't anything for us to
do we'd let us get in line and look did
you look yeah look dude dude it was so
awesome I couldn't even see that's how
awesome it was like
I would look and I was [__] we were
done I was blind about my own excitement
for it like [__] dog I'd be like dude I
didn't see him and he's like you just
[__] looked like but I [__] didn't
see dude
damn you're so excited oh yeah we were
God we were so excited
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one